- [Voiceover] Let inverted, or upside down
triangle x, be defined
as x plus one over x.
Let me write that down.
Inverted triangle x,
is equal to x plus one over x.
For all non-zero integers x,
all right, if inverted or upside down
triangle x is equal to t.
So if this whole thing is equal to t,
where t is an integer,
which of the following
is a possible value of t.
So let's think about this a little bit.
So, what you could try to do,
is you could take each of these choices,
and substitute it in for t,
and then try to solve for x,
and see if you can find
x's that are integers.
But instead of doing
each of them one by one,
let's just rearrange this equation
where we can solve for
x as a function of t.
And then we could try
the different t values
out (mumbles), and say,
can we get a non-zero
integer value for x?
So if we take this, and if we multiply
both sides by x, we're going to get
x times x is x squared.
One over x times x is one.
And then t times x is tx.
Now, it looks like we have a quadratic,
we could try to get into a standard form
so we could try to factor it.
So let's subtract tx from both sides.
And so if we subtract tx,
from both sides, we are going
to be left with, on the left-hand side,
x squared minus tx plus one,
and that's going to be equal to zero.
Now this is interesting right over here.
We have, kind of, a traditional quadratic.
A traditional quadratic
equation right over here.
We just have to think about, well,
for what values of t can
we actually factor this
so that we can integer solutions for x.
So, actually, let's just write down
all the options over here.
So if t is equal to one,
then this thing is going to be x squared
minus one x, so we could just say,
x squared minus x plus one.
If t is equal to zero,
then this middle term disappears,
and you're just left
with x squared plus one.
If t is equal to negative one,
then this thing becomes x squared,
negative, negative one,
so it's plus x plus one.
If t is equal to negative two,
then you get x squared
plus two x, plus one.
And then if t is equal to...
I'm running out of colors.
If t is equal to negative three,
you have x squared plus
negative, negative three,
so that's plus three x plus one.
So which of these can you factor?
Well, it might jump out at you that,
hey, this is a perfect
square right over here,
I could factor this one.
This is x plus one times x plus one.
One plus one is two,
and one times one is one
right over here.
So because I can factor this,
I know that this right over here
is going to be my answer.
If t is equal to negative two,
then all of this stuff boils down to that,
and we could say that x squared
minus t, which is plus two,
plus two x plus one is equal to zero.
The left-hand side is
just x plus one squared
is equal to zero, which
means that x plus one
is equal to zero, which means that
x would be equal to negative one.
So when t is equal to negative two,
that means that x is
equal to negative one,
and negative one is a non-zero integer.
You can look at these other ones,
and you say, well, yeah, this is very hard
to factor, I need to take the product
of two numbers, whose positive one,
and their sum is negative one.
Well I can't think of two integers
that would do that.
Same thing here, x squared plus one,
how do I factor that?
There's no obvious way, at least
in my brain, of factoring that.
Same thing over here, two numbers,
whose product is one and whose sum
is positive one, well, I needed
two integers, and I
can't think of any there.
And same thing over here,
two numbers whose product is one,
and whose sum is three,
can't think of it.
But this one, right over here, you can.